Attorney General Jeff Sessions will
testify today at a public hearing of the
Senate Intelligence Committee senators
are expected to ask questions about the
firing of FBI director James Comey and
any contacts and sessions had with
Russian officials during the campaign
the Attorney General as you may remember
withdrew from the Russia investigation
in March after the news after news that
he did not disclose to meetings with
Russia's US ambassador last year
senators are also likely to ask sessions
about a meeting where Comey said the
president spoke to him about dropping
the investigation of former national
security advisor Michael Flynn the
committee meets after a friend of
President Trump said the president is
thinking of firing Special Counsel
Robert Muller major Garrett is at the
White House with the administration's
response to that claim major good
morning the White House said through
spokesman Sean Spicer that Christopher
ruddy the conservative media mogul who
floated this idea didn't talk to the
president directly on this subject and
only the president's attorneys could one
problem one of the president's attorneys
Jay Sekulow said on Sunday that it
wasn't she wasn't sure whether Trump
would fire Muller only that it's a power
he could exercise for his part Rudd he
told us this morning he found Spicer
statement bizarre in that it did not
deny the president was considering
ousting the newly appointed special
counsel but he also told us something he
said to others memo DeSean don't waste
your time trying to undermine one of
your few allies majors jeff Sessions
prepared to or perhaps he will testify
about Jarrad cushion of the president's
son-in-law well these two things could
come together Charlie in this way there
have been reports that sessions has
vociferously denied that he had a third
undisclosed meeting with the Russian
ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac the date
April of 2016 when then candidate Trump
was giving his first major foreign
policy speech Jared Kushner was a
co-author of that speech the two I'm
told rode together to that speech but
did not depart at the same time and
there is talk that there was an
encounter with kiss lyac and others
session said he was never in that room
Kushner was in that room but those close
to him described it as just
General Meeting not a one-on-one
Kushner's activities there could be
further scrutinized he is still working
on details with the Senate Intelligence
Committee about when he will testify all
right major thank you so much